you know also I wanted to know if there
was if law enforcement how they were
dealing with some of the if there was a
spike in crime or what like that and we
had a well we had two officers that
called I want to get one right here
listen to this VM right here okay here
we go let's get the fuzz on the line
here what's up video my name's Isaiah
man you said any officers of the wall
call in with your statements about the
domestics right now right now just go to
the cove it and everything going on
Thank You Isaiah thanks for your service
and thanks for and thanks for calling in
brother let's hear more and yeah man
it's been it's been crazy out here dude
I mean I think in the month of March
alone domestics where I'm from a double
I'm in a Dayton Ohio area gang [ __ ]
Dayton baby then flyers huh what about
your boy Troutman I think he just got
drafted by the New Orleans Saints Blaine
you know it mm-hmm
and also if you've never been to the
United Air Force Museum I think it's
called in Dayton I would go out on a
limb to call it probably one of the top
six museums in America one of the top
six American museums or Mew sales which
is Spanish let's hear more sir so we had
a domestic guy a couple weeks back
homeboy sneaking out a fire escape
dude he gets down this fire escape
getting out and he's [ __ ] realizes
there's no ladder to take him from here
to there to the ground he's just stuck
up there you know
shirtless he's got his shorts on he's
like [ __ ] man we're standing in the
alleyway hey man you got nowhere to go
so you know that's just a little glimpse
of what it's like but uh appreciate you
man keep it up keep up the good work
okay thank you sir appreciate appreciate
the call yeah and that's real I mean a
lot of men stranded on the fire escape
aren't they
all right I mean that's just a euphemism
for mayor of my damn heart because that
is just that should be our national bird
a shirtless man on a fire escape with
nowhere to go
let me name a better one didn't think
you could not should mean yeah and two
officers down there like look buddy we
might look then jump then jump buck
aroni
okay jump if you survived it I'll take
you over there to boot get of epidemic
in a you know down by the Southside down
by the Dame water and we'll buy you a
freakin uh pepperoni bread hmm but yeah
that's really oh that's how I feel about
a lot of times I feel shirtless and I
feel like I'm just on the fire escape of
my own life praise God brother thank you
for that sir and you guys stay safe out
there
but yeah domestics are going up the mess
is going up
oh my Sunday you know that she's getting
hot you know it's getting hot in the
house a lot of spouses saying hey uh
honey will you turn the AC on it is on
okay it is on Ronald it's ladies night
it is on cut it on Jack
the AC is oh really Dan cos it's hot in
here
it sure is that's cuz we got two hundred
degrees of your [ __ ]
and a lot of these spotty a Slade ease
out there to being sneaky and being a
little snack I'd back those you know in
text and different men and stuff like
this and Facebook and they college
heroes and [ __ ] I'm telling you man
these domestics it's because you can't
put if you put too much fire and a
furnace brush something's gonna get
cooked mmm and hey look I hate to say it
but we might end up with a few beautiful
episodes of Dateline out of all of this
and I don't want people to die but I do
want more Dateline and you just you know
that's you got to wonder how that'll all
work out we had another little officer
of the law that called in let's get that
call here hey yo this is Kyle what's up
Kyle out of st. Louis and st. Louis is
famous for the arch and also for this
comedians up-and-coming comedian Chris
D'Elia actually he's cancelled there
doing his show there let's hear more in
my glass Jim doing some prison yard work
out listen Martin time ask you to say
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that prison
your old work out that's nice to do by
yourself and not have to do an actual
prison where after the workout you got
to watch some guy bust out or you do you
know I'm saying you got to at least
stand there and look excited while
somebody jacks off so you don't get you
know abused or sexually abused gang
Brown work and you have to be posed the
question of law enforcement it's a mess
with violence is up my girlfriend she
happens to be a police officer and she
said the numbers up to 25 to 35 percent
in her jurisdiction pretty crazy stuff I
think people need to get out get away
from each other
she may kill me - I hope not we both
love the show keep up the great work be
careful be safe Gang Gang Gang bra and
thank you two for your feet - beautiful
lady for her service Wow dawg
yeah that's the thing you gotta get out
go take a drive take a bike get a
two-seater bike and cut the back off of
that [ __ ] and do a one-seater you know
get in a wheel barrow dog on a downhill
go be by yourself
you know what I'm saying live you gotta
take some time play hide-and-go-seek
have your wife go count and you drive
out of town and get a motel somewhere I
mean that's easy
you have to just you know it has to be
you know you you got to separate from
each other
especially if you have a weapon if you
have a weapon buried a weapon give it to
your friend barri give it to your friend
bury the original burying the weapon
don't [ __ ] don't
you know you don't want to put a gun in
the dirt man you want to but good you
know have it somewhere else where you
can't use it if you want to shoot a
spouse you have to do you a handgun do
you know make a little gun with your
hand or draw a gun and throw it at them
you know draw it on a little sheet of
something uh legal pad but thank you for
calling man I like that getting a prison
workout getting it done on your own good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one